hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
my March 23rd 2020 what's going on I in
the future are you coming back listening
to this how long did the pandemic land
that it turned into an epidemic is that
what it is pandemic pandemic is like the
triple length of a disease he's almost
at the show he's still hitting [ __ ]
dirty baseballs all right it's a woman
remember that [ __ ]
remember feminism that's the one good
thing about the pandemic that [ __ ]
all went away all those white broads
[ __ ] moaning and complaining with their
own [ __ ] TV shows getting awards for
saying [ __ ] that other people wrote my
life is so hurry dad I don't know you
know what you know what this is gonna be
a great day I might say why this is a
great day you know we just wake up with
the [ __ ] song in your head
I have Robbie Dupree steal away in my
head you know and I'm gonna warn you
okay you know with social distancing and
all of this [ __ ] the last thing you need
is some [ __ ] bald freckled [ __ ] on a
podcast getting a song in your head but
I'm about ready to sing it and I'm gonna
tell you this song it's so [ __ ]
catchy especially when I sing it it's
gonna be in your ear - all right come on
would be come on and hold me but just
like you told me I woke up with this man
then [ __ ] show me what I want to know
why don't we steal away
boop-boo-boo-boop
why don't we see
way into the nighttime because there's a
pandemic
hello kovaydin 19 much hashtag shaking
my head how about all the [ __ ] store in
this [ __ ] pandemic that you think god
forbid there alone with their own
[ __ ] thoughts eating some [ __ ]
cookie dough just can't do it gotta go
hang out with their friends hang out
with her you dumped [ __ ] you have you
she could have gone out blown a trucker
since the last time she saw you you
don't know what she does you don't know
what she's into man she's that close to
you huh
how about you buddy you gonna be a
[ __ ] man you're gonna John Wayne you
[ __ ] your way through this [ __ ] are you
gonna be a [ __ ] you know yoga studio
person we're all connected I'll tell you
what is what Donald Trump is stirring up
with that whole Chinese virus thing that
he's doing I'll tell you what you know
what I guess we all are connected cuz
evidently is some guy on the other side
of the planet stick his dick in some
bats but next thing you know I can't sit
out on a lake bass fishing with one of
my buddies I swear to [ __ ] god the
left and the right
when are they just gonna man up face a
[ __ ] problem and try and solve it
without finger-pointing like some
douchey quarterback going back to the
huddle it's too funny what [ __ ] good
does that do well that's where that came
from okay is that the game we're playing
dude do we think is this country this is
that we're gonna survive that game [ __ ]
sitting there pointing fingers as we're
drone bombing weddings
we got economic sanctions against Iran
so they can't even [ __ ] help their
people slavery genocide rate racism
sysm where the [ __ ] mad cow disease
come from that came from [ __ ] England
do we call that the the British
disappointed cow whatever the [ __ ] was
supposed to call it didn't we bring up a
bunch of [ __ ] diseases Koff on
blankets and then [ __ ] give him the
Native Americans I mean jesus [ __ ]
christ I swear to God goddamn
Republicans and Democrats anytime
there's a [ __ ] problem they get their
panties in a bunch and they just start
pointing well good
I remember when Obama came into office
he goes well I inherited these wars I
inherited this blah blah blah blah blah
next thing you know he's playing video
games [ __ ] drone bomb and people at a
[ __ ] picnic anyways people all right
there's all kinds of viruses evidently
around the [ __ ] world they're in the
goddamn rain forests that were chopping
down everyday were [ __ ] doing that
eventually one of them's gonna get out
and everybody just [ __ ] do what they
tell you to do just [ __ ] stay inside
don't interact with other goddamn people
stop being [ __ ] selfish let's just
all [ __ ] come together right now we
should be doing is avoiding one another
and then going online and trying to
figure out how people who don't have
money for food we can get them some food
well people who are you know living week
to week how maybe we can do some sort of
startup or some sort of benefit that we
should [ __ ] help each other out we
just ignore the politicians who are just
gonna get the mouth-breathers all
[ __ ] stirred up again you know this
is some snowflake stuff but I can't call
it a Chinese virus you know let me ask
you this who's you know if somebody
really looked at your life and all this
[ __ ] you did would you hold up to that
level of scrutiny that there couldn't be
something named after you all right jeez
it's a there's a [ __ ] billion people
if you lived over there you'd be eating
all kinds of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] oh I
would imagine I imagine there's some
[ __ ] that we eat over here that they
think is [ __ ] nuts there's a part of
the world that
Scouse is sacred we shouldn't he be
[ __ ] eating them and we're over here
feeding cows to other [ __ ] cows
alright
we have been the problem collectively
humanity for a long [ __ ] time because
I'll tell you right now how clear is the
sky right now without all those Jets
flying around and people driving around
living their best lives going down to
malls buying [ __ ] that they don't
[ __ ] need think about that man
we are the guy that I just say think
about that am i lecturing you I'm sorry
sorry I just [ __ ] can't stand i don't
not say that I don't have my own [ __ ]
faults and I haven't been guilty of
being a [ __ ] meathead because I have
I do my best to try to avoid doing [ __ ]
like Donnie T's doing right now coming
back to the huddle [ __ ] pointing
people out I remember [ __ ] guys used
to do that and next thing you know
they're [ __ ] offensive line wouldn't
block for him anymore then he'd have to
take everybody out for a [ __ ] steak
dinner which is also a collar I was at a
steer well what happens you [ __ ] city
slickers a goddamn bull gets up on his
hind quarters and sticks his bull [ __ ]
into a [ __ ] cow they [ __ ] a right if
they have a Holmen cat it's called a cow
they have a man it's called a bull they
cut the balls off it becomes a [ __ ]
stare and that's where your goddamn
steak comes from I learned that when I
was in Wyoming or Colorado somewhere out
there all right so let's let's just I
don't think we need to name this thing
and blame a [ __ ] group of people how
come we didn't call it the French French
AIDS
the French stewardess aids male
stewardess AIDS why don't we call it
that hey by the way maybe it wasn't
French let me see where was that guy
from let's find out where everything why
don't we find out right now where all
the disease
came from and named them accurately
alright first AIDS patient April 24th
San Francisco resident Ken Horn is
reported the center disease in later 98
way way way late with elf Oh is he the
Stewart is he was just a fluid of France
is that what it was
so why is it at the American aids USA
AIDS
USAID's oh thanks too long now I can't
stick my dick and somebody's bum without
getting [ __ ] or animals to people or
animals we eat [ __ ] we [ __ ] [ __ ] and and
you know we we [ __ ] what about the
baby boom generation you know [ __ ]
out there Woodstock's rolling around
[ __ ] in the mud they they didn't they
didn't cause something is that what I'm
supposed to believe what am I even
talking about now I don't know so anyway
[Music]
give it up for ESPN 2 that became ESPN 8
ar e SPN Oh Joe give it up for them I've
been watching it but I guess this
showing [ __ ] dodgeball belly flop calm
competitions and all of this [ __ ] and
everybody's going nuts like this is
[ __ ] amazing this is what ESPN did in
the beginning
well they had all that time to [ __ ]
Phil it was incredible that's a good
thing that's a good thing to check out
bar Tony man this is a great time right
now for you to do a bunch of things that
you never did the last time I mentioned
it's a great time to shave your head if
you ever wanted to shave your head this
is a great time it's a great time to buy
a boat buy a motorcycle a classic car
something in aviation this is a great
time to buy it's a little parasitic
but that's how it works that's how the
game is played
if you squirrel away you touch during
the good times when the [ __ ] turns down
and that
buddy out there was living like the new
Johnny Bravo as they did on the Brady
Bunch
you know walking around with you [ __ ]
sexy goddamn shirt so your step sister
wants to bang you or maybe even your
stepmother alright Dave this should
happen man this [ __ ] happened on the
Brady Bunch
maybe they created a [ __ ] disease on
that goddamn show Greg baby banging
[ __ ] Mrs Brady in real life Barry
[ __ ] Florence
Oh Barry all Florence oh Jesus
anyway yeah this is this is the [ __ ]
time you don't buy a boat during a virus
free booming economic time which by the
way that's a big fallacy by the way
everybody was saying that the economy
was booming the economy was booming
before before this [ __ ] [ __ ]
happened it's just like how many [ __ ]
times are you going to ignore how much
money we're spending on these
never-ending [ __ ] wars and how many
[ __ ] times are you gonna let these
[ __ ] banker [ __ ] these [ __ ] bank
accounts create a new real estate some
sort of [ __ ] bubble it's a bubble
people we were living in a bubble it's
the [ __ ] high-end luxury apartment
rental buildings going up on every other
[ __ ] block which is all our money
which is all our money and there's a
finite amount of people from China and
Russia that have so much money that they
need to wash it by [ __ ] you know buy
in one of these goddamn condos and then
once that happens once that runs out and
the cranes are still building the whole
thing topples down again and then
whoever's in office red tie or blue tie
gets blamed and then the bankers start
on new [ __ ] scheme I know all of this
[ __ ] because I skim read a couple of
articles this is why you should be
listening to me and not the people on
[ __ ] CNN and Fox right
anyway there's really just nothing to
talk about is there this is just this is
when you separate the men from the boys
by the way how [ __ ] brilliant wasn't
since the beginning of podcasting that I
never had a guest all right so my show
has not changed at all everybody else
all my compadres out there they're all
like ah God can you Skype into this can
can you Skype into that what's the
[ __ ] password not old freckles all
freckles sits there in his Jam jams and
did it does it like he always did it
right like that old guy who never sold
out to McDonald's and kept his own
[ __ ] hamburger recipe and then got
buried by McDonald's anyways you know
then they made a documentary about him
and people like wow that's pretty
[ __ ] cool but he guys still dies
penniless I still been drumming actually
I have so much [ __ ] free time now
I don't really because I got my kid but
we've been playing dude she's a lefty
she throws right but she bats left
she's a lefty in the lineup and she's
[ __ ] crushing it she got the tee ball
going you know she's so goddamn cute she
keeps saying she goes to me she goes dad
I want you to take me to a ball game I'm
like you want to go to a baseball game
she kind of looks to me I want you to
take me to ball game and I'm thinking
and I'm like you want me ticket and then
I realized she heard that song take me
out to the ball game so what she's
really saying is she wants me to sing
the song so then I gotta go take me out
to the ball game take me out to the
crowd
[Music]
I don't give I get back right I do the
whole [ __ ] song and she's pretending
to swing a bat
the whole time I guess she saw it on one
of her a little kids show thinks and the
best part is when I go for it's one two
three strikes you're uh she swings the
bat each time the big smile on her face
it's the cutest damn thing ever so and
she's fast she can haul ass definitely
did not get that for me she got it from
a mother Nia you were always fast as a
kid right hello um anyway yeah she got
the speed she got the speed from from my
lovely wife and then she got the lefty
thing from me because I'm left I'm weird
I'm mommy I'm all over the map I play
guitar left-handed I drum right-handed I
write left-handed I can do tools either
either way but I think I do i do all
sports right-handed although I kind of
switched to left-handed when I [ __ ] up
my shoulder my right shoulder but now my
right shoulder is good so all the [ __ ] I
learn with my left shoulder I'm going
back and relearning with my right I'm a
[ __ ] up dude
all right I'm a [ __ ] up too but let's
get let's let's look up some [ __ ] let's
look a boat for sale boat for sale look
at that I get a goddamn so I get a
[ __ ] 60 square foot whatever that
means
27 foot sailboat for 1,300 bucks a
luxury yacht for 300 $44.99 how about an
abandoned dilapidated ship for $10.85 I
mean these deals did not exist this guy
62 foot yacht all right now in the
yachting world I learned this when I was
in the French Riviera
I was in San Tropez smoking Cubans went
but a PIPA but get inside you pasty
freckled [ __ ] it smoky cigar your
unsightly I learned over there that when
the yachting world it's a million Amina
and let's see a metre is a little more
than a yard if I remember from my
childhood so three in 262 goes in there
won't see two times so that should be a
twenty million dollar boat right roughly
this guy's dropping this thing for four
million bucks
now I'm sure it needs some new spark
plugs the Illuminati spark plugs right
this thing was 4.3 million dollars it's
now down to three point nine five and
I'm gonna tell you right now that is not
a [ __ ] yacht Titan yacht 62-foot
sports fish a femaie from downy yachts
that's not a yacht that's let's that's
one of those [ __ ] ones that have fat
white guy with a big red face buys and
he goes out there with the Sun you know
and they take pictures of holding up the
fish right before the guy he [ __ ]
gets a fatal attack of gout you know
from just living a great life I always
like those big fat [ __ ] white dudes
with the red faces that owned a boat you
know what I mean both people are [ __ ]
cool you know
motorcycle people are cool people that
like guys that [ __ ] still have a toy
a guy that can be married I gotta say
this quietly so I don't [ __ ] up my life
here a guy that's married and still can
go out and buy a toy like that you know
what I love when I see that I'm like
that guy has his woman in line alright
he's either [ __ ] married and he's
still calling the show he's crushing it
so hard that she can't say no to the
boat she can't say no to the fact that
he liked that new Indian motorcycle and
he went down
and ordered that [ __ ] custom [ __ ]
paint job he's crushing it so hard right
or maybe he's like that Brad Pitt
character right
he doesn't need a woman it only mean
he's just an been [ __ ] once upon a
time in Hollywood anyways this you can
get a 62 foot sports fish Effie May from
downy yachts for 3.95 I don't know used
to be 4.3 I have no idea what a [ __ ]
boats cause let's take a look at this
[ __ ] thing huh
this thing just reeks of [ __ ]
shadiness did you show us showing the
thing [ __ ] tooling around I don't see
anywhere where you were inside the boat
I don't like this you know I would do if
I ever bought one of these boats the fur
oh look at that nice king-size [ __ ]
bed sheet down there praying to God in
the middle of a [ __ ] perfect storm if
I [ __ ] live down there man I would
[ __ ] know if I had a but if I ever
bought a boat the first thing you got to
do is you got a you got to get it
you got to get a [ __ ] buddy who's a
cop with a dog sniffing with it with a
yeah dog sniffing a drug sniffing dog
dog sniffing dog they all sniff dunks
all right the Ivy League dog can find
cocaine and I'd say get this [ __ ]
thing on this goddamn boat and find out
if there's not an extra kilo of
something hidden somewhere because I
don't want to get pulled over by the
Coast Guard you know and take the fall
for whatever this is or when the [ __ ]
Diaz brothers show when they [ __ ]
show up for their lost [ __ ] kilo I
don't need the [ __ ] that's that's the
number one thing you got to do
I wonder if [ __ ] helicopters are
content let's let's do a little [ __ ]
dream shop in here during a [ __ ]
pandemic what about those [ __ ]
senator [ __ ] they find out what was
going down they pulled their money out
of the stock market you know so pull
your money out and then an hour later
wait an hour and then [ __ ] look give
us the heads up they don't even do that
dude I'm telling you right now all of
these [ __ ] support the troops
[ __ ] blare all foolish [ __ ] when the
[ __ ] hits the fan it's every man for
himself which is why what I'm trying to
do is hear on this podcast well what I'm
really trying to do is fill up this hour
who's kidding who but other than that
I'm trying to [ __ ] get people to come
this is the time to come together this
is not a time grab two handfuls of that
rope and you pull in the same direction
as everybody else [ __ ] these [ __ ]
leaders scaring the [ __ ] out of
everybody [ __ ] these news 24-hour news
programs scaring the [ __ ] out of
everybody [ __ ] these [ __ ] politicians
who just want to call it a Chinese virus
and all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] all of that
[ __ ] we're all in this together all
right this is not a time to start some
Hatfield and McCoys [ __ ] so [ __ ]
everything that they're saying all right
everybody just [ __ ] stays in chills
out we do some whatever we can do to
help out people who don't have food or
[ __ ] money let's let's spend your
energy rather than freaking out figure
out how to help somebody all right
without getting contaminated would you
add that I'm not saying that's an easy
thing all right
helicopter for sale you could [ __ ]
shave your head
change your name walk around in women's
clothes whatever this is the time to do
it and buy a helicopter all in the same
[ __ ] day you can just finally
stop ignoring you know all of society's
not am I just saying you're just gonna
go [ __ ] crazy all right look at that
a twenty20 Robinson r44 for 387 grand
how many hours does it have left on it
oh it's in Florida [ __ ] that God knows
what that [ __ ] idiot did with that
thing [ __ ] yanking the [ __ ] out of it
[ __ ] you
20:20 Robinson r44 clipper 440 $4,000
these things haven't really come down
yet to 2013 are 66 for 725
2004 ends from 280 FX shark and ever
even heard of that oh there it is oh
there she is
1997 McDonnell Douglas 600 n that's one
of those [ __ ] magnum p.i ones they
want seven hundred and seventy-five
thousand dollars for looking at a bell
this 1965 Bell 447 G for 80 grand
I know 1965 don't worry depart to new
right that's what they tell you the
parts are all brand-new set 775 or best
offer it's got the [ __ ] note our
system I'm back to the the MacDonald
McDonnell Douglas six and look at this
[ __ ] thing it's on trade a plane calm
let's see what she has she's [ __ ]
read like my goddamn beard used to be
whoo let's see the OT got the glass
cockpit gonna the note our system so you
can land in Santa Monica without all the
rich [ __ ] complaining about how [ __ ]
loud it is dude this thing is like
period blood red though it's kind of
cool so everybody will see when you're
up in the sky you know that's a great
thing if somebody runs into you up day
and you both [ __ ] crash and live and
you have to be ahead of [ __ ] did you not
see me Oh five-bladed main rotor system
where were the seats in the back Jesus
Christ what people skydiving out of this
[ __ ] thing oh it's got an analogue
[ __ ] analog gauges
I like analog gauges I'm trying to get
into the glass cockpits but they sleep
they they don't know I'm not going with
computers and [ __ ] oh my god oh my God
look at that look at that right there if
you got money if you got money
this purse is selling
I would wait they know now you got to
play the game like how long do i wait I
love those [ __ ] they got these things
these wire cutters on the front of the
goddamn telephone line cutters in the
front of these [ __ ] helicopters do
you ever see a helicopter right and it's
got like these two like [ __ ]
triangles like sharp things one on the
bottom one on the top allegedly
so it says you're cruising along at
about 90 knots and you hit some those
high-powered lines which kills more
goddamn helicopter pilots than anything
if you hit one of those things allegedly
rather than the [ __ ] wire going
through the [ __ ] you know windshield
whatever the [ __ ] you call it in
aviation it [ __ ] decapitating you or
just slicing you in the half you know
through your torso it just slides up the
windshield hits that thing and it cuts
it geez imagine if it does that I can't
imagine the how many [ __ ] people are
sitting there waiting for you to land
how much money you owe the state fly it
around show it off then you're like you
[ __ ] cut the thing in half and then
all the lights below you just go dark
and now you went from [ __ ] VFR
there's no moon now you're in IFR and
you [ __ ] survived the goddamn wire
and now what the [ __ ] do you do you got
a gut you got a [ __ ] get some
altitude try to get high enough up to
get beyond the blackout you just caused
Jesus Christ now that's a [ __ ]
situation yeah but look at this twenty20
Robinson are 66 this guy who sells the
[ __ ] twenty20 other than Robinson
Florida Suncoast helicopters they just
drop in you know because nobody's going
down there nobody's going down to see
people so there are some deals to be had
out there is everybody's hoarding toilet
paper you know what I mean you could be
flying around in your own helicopter for
a goddamn deal [ __ ] out the side
right down into a supermarket parking
lot now these are this is the kind of
fun that can be had people if you don't
just focus on the negative
all right talk speaking of trying to
help people out all right back in the
day when I used to do all of these gigs
down in Rhode Island this comedian and
local promoter John Parata what's going
on brother John Parata Billy burrow is
going on brother I got a room for you
too and he's the [ __ ] book
periwinkles and all of this [ __ ] down
and [ __ ] Rhode Island it's going on
Bravo
well he has his son named David Parata
and he wrote a [ __ ] best-selling book
called conversation Casanova do you need
some reading
would you like to hit the ground running
you know and start crushing some ass
when it's close when it's okay to get
close to some ass when this whole
pandemic is over well I can't recommend
David Piratas book conversation Casanova
which you can get on Amazon conversation
Casanova how to effortlessly start
conversations and flirt like a pro it's
got four and a half out of five stars
all right good enough for a gold medal
when everybody's doing the triple lindy
so check that out if you get a chance
well how much is it bill how much is
this gonna [ __ ] tip it's [ __ ]
$4.99 that's the Kindle Price save ten
bucks it's 15 bucks all right you know
maybe you're a shy person see maybe
you'll like this [ __ ] being
quarantined in this type of thing but
you know it's time for you to come out
of your shell you're gonna come out you
know you're gonna have you [ __ ] sexy
clothes on all right when your neighbor
who was getting all kinds of [ __ ] dies
from this [ __ ] disease you wait a few
days you go in you take his clothes all
right now you got the clothes of a gov a
[ __ ] getting guy but you don't have the
[ __ ] rat man well you get this
[ __ ] book and you have it see there's
all kinds of [ __ ] advantages here oh
by the way the wild animals are
reclaiming [ __ ] territories everybody
stays inside somebody sent me a video
there's one mountain lion in Los Angeles
all right and that thing you know if you
live I don't know where it is it's in
one of these the Hollywood Hills
somewhere around here but somebody had
video a buddy of mine his friend had
like this video camera set up you know
like a security thing and when I tell
you this [ __ ] cougar this mountain
lion just went right by like he had like
a sliding glass window he lived on like
the second floor of an apartment
building and this thing just came
walking along you know local he's just
like you know little house cats will run
along the railing of your balcony that's
what this [ __ ] thing was doing it
just came walking by I always feel bad
for like those [ __ ] little dogs and
[ __ ] they get caught by you know the
Coyotes and stuff you know I saw this
video one time and I felt so bad for
this little dog it was sleeping and the
Cougar came up and it doesn't quite know
what that dog is so it just kind of
[ __ ] swiped at it with its paw and
the dog woke up and it was the little
[ __ ] man I feel so but he was trying
to be brave he was trying to bark at it
but it was she was just too scary it was
over in an instant though I just walked
I was like that was it okay and I got a
lot out of that I was like if that
[ __ ] thing got up and had its man
barked and charged the [ __ ] Cougar I
think the Cougar runs away for it's
weird
those big [ __ ] cats man they they you
can freak them out easy an aggressive
move especially when they're coming up
and they don't know what the [ __ ] you
are you know you got like a belt on and
a [ __ ] college shirt they're you know
wearing it [ __ ] bose noise-canceling
headset they don't know what they're
eating it's like that looks like there's
some meat underneath all of that and you
just make a [ __ ] you know you got
that one move where they turn tail and
then you got time to run back to the
land row right you got that one [ __ ]
moment if you don't [ __ ] yourself
can you make an aggressive move and you
just cause them for half a second to be
like wait a minute what the [ __ ] is this
thing and then by the time they figure
out you're [ __ ] running again
hopefully you're back in there and you
can put the windows up aren't there guys
on the on the interweb doing that [ __ ] I
mean god dammit these [ __ ] people
around the world eating goddamn
grasshoppers and [ __ ] I'm just sitting
out here on the property guys out there
eating a [ __ ] flying rat anyway uh
once again shout out to all the Doomsday
Preppers who was they were [ __ ] ready
for this [ __ ] they got cans of [ __ ]
beans to last forever I have a way to
solve the economic problem too by the
way by the way by the way by the way but
it would involved the bankers being
generous you know I don't understand why
politicians don't just pressure bankers
put them right on that cuz they'll
[ __ ] give them a convertible ride
Dallas we all know how that goes right
this is this is what you do all you do
during this [ __ ] pandemic because
nobody can work for the most part except
the potential people right this is what
you do you just act like the world
economy is a video game and we all hit
pause because we had to get up and take
a [ __ ] or go make a [ __ ] sandwich
alright so let's say this thing lasts
from March to May alright in May or in
June when the whole thing starts back up
again you get to go back to work
you just make make your next mortgage
payment like it was March it's just
called June now and we just we just
these last things we're on pause
everything's just on [ __ ] pause and
that's the smartest thing these [ __ ]
bankers can do so they don't get caught
because we all know that all of these
economies are nothing more than
elaborate at the highest level
see schemes in Ponzi schemes all work
until the [ __ ] wheels stop turning
and once the wheels stop turning
it just needs forward momentum it just
has to keep rolling along everybody's
buying the deal everybody thinks that
they put the money in the bank and it's
still there and they still have their
[ __ ] you know I look it up online and
I see all those numbers so it has to be
there that is the best move these
[ __ ] bankers can make you know
they're knocking I don't know hopefully
they'll [ __ ] do something like that
you know that's the thing when you run
into scam as long as it's moving forward
everything's fine when you stop the
width of your own [ __ ] overpowers
everybody and then they know what you're
doing it reminds me a long time ago I
don't know if this is a true story but I
was in between LA and New York and I got
rid of my LA apartment is like [ __ ] this
made it go back to New York I should
have just sold everything but I held on
to a car out here and a couple other
things because I wanted to have a car
during pilot season there's to be a
thing called pilot season and it was
funny to come out here to do a bunch of
reads for a bunch of acting work that I
didn't even want at that point in my
[ __ ] career this lady down at the
storage unit told me that you know this
where I was leaving my car and some of
my [ __ ] that this was a this was a a
chain the storage shed and that they had
had a deal at one of their other storage
sheds there was a guy who used to come
in like every other day and he had a big
giant storage shed he had a freezer in
there and all of this type of [ __ ] right
well the guy ends up having a flunk on
the second floor the guy ends up having
a [ __ ] medical issue heart attack
cancer I don't know what happened he
lives alone has no family right he
[ __ ] goes to the hospital he can't
make his payments so they shut off the
electricity
in the [ __ ] freezer that he had and
then this [ __ ] odor came out of him
they opened it up and he had like
[ __ ] dead bodies and [ __ ] and he
killed I forget it we killed I don't
know it was I was gonna say it was his
family but I would think people would
notice that his family was gone they
would investigate him and then they
would figure out he had a [ __ ]
storage shed when they had a freezer and
that mattre be in that cup and there's a
[ __ ] giant goddamn freezer big enough
to put a [ __ ] elk in there like you
Joe Rogan right and then you [ __ ]
lift lifting that top up god what a
[ __ ] job and what a job just seeing
the [ __ ] worst in people alright
let's let's read some advertising here
everybody what a way to go into
advertising you know after I got you all
excited to buy a boat or a [ __ ]
motorcycle so I'm like how good did the
[ __ ] Indians look huh I mean this is
a great time great time to write a
[ __ ] motorcycle great [ __ ] time
LegalZoom everybody attacks chairs
that's the one thing we all have to deal
with this time of year and as a business
owner it's critical to know all your
options that's why you should lean on
LegalZoom yes absolutely you should be
doing this because those [ __ ] are
they're letting you basically you know
file later or something like that
together but think you can always do
that
the fact that these banker [ __ ] won't
have a [ __ ] heart you know what I
mean so how about we just hit pause
nobody owns a or anybody anything until
this [ __ ] thing's over and then we
just start with it there's no interest
there's none of that [ __ ] everything's
on pause alright nobody has to pay that
[ __ ] rent and then the land the your
your landlord doesn't owe anybody money
nobody owes anybody [ __ ] any goddamn
money just [ __ ] chill I mean
obviously you have to pay for your food
everybody just [ __ ] relaxes you know
you just hit pause why can't they just
do that
Oh cuz they're greedy well that's why
you need legalism all right have you or
anyone you know used LegalZoom for their
business have you received any feedback
from listeners have yous LegalZoom no I
haven't why would you ask those
questions I would have brought it up
LLC's DBAs and s corpse they all mean
different things when it comes to paying
taxes and limiting your personal
liability there's a lot to think about
but with LegalZoom you don't have to
worry about doing all the legwork
yourself to find the right answers they
have a ton of resources to help
including their network of independent
attorneys and tax professionals they'll
provide the advice you need to ensure
you're operating your business the way
you want to and since LegalZoom isn't a
law firm you'll save time and money
while avoiding hourly fees whether you
need to incorporate form an LLC or set
up your business another way use Legal
Zoom to maximize your business potential
and make your account accountant happy
go to legalzoom.com today to get your
business on the right track for 2020
Legal Zoom where life meets legal oh
look who's here classic but who do B
undies the undies don't [ __ ] breathe
on me to doot-doot-doot me undies be
undies you sneeze and now I can't see
thanks a lot for [ __ ] that bad and
all the old people died and you if
you're fat because it's a pandemic but
you want to look good when the coronor
picks you up so get some me undies
alright why would you need an undo
membership honestly because it's fun
it's an easy way to give yourself your
future self a present each month a
membership with me undies is full of
perks like site-wide savings early
access free shipping and new
ridiculously soft undies delivered to
your door each month building your
undies collection make sure adult life
just a tad easier more undies equals
less laundry it's science
yeah but it's more [ __ ] space taking
up you know just find some undies I mean
you've anyway you've probably heard me
undies are the softest undies to ever
grace your nethers the nether re
that's because they're made with micro
motile modal what the heck is that
it's a magical substance Sophos heck
fabric made from trees yes trees that
makes your bits feel like they're
floating on a cloud and who doesn't want
that
who doesn't want elevated nuts during
this time they're designed to be the
softest things you ever put on your body
and offered in a range of sizes from
extra small to 4 XL you can have it for
everybody with a micropenis
to elephantitis of the nuts they got the
[ __ ] softest underwear in the game
they also have loungewear which recently
had a glow up what does that mean check
out their new line of stylee micro Motel
loungewear
you can wear in and out of the house the
undies has a great offer from my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15% off and free shipping this
is a no-brainer especially because they
have 100% satisfaction guaranteed to get
your 15% off your first order
free shipping 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies comm / /
that's me undies com / / oh and then
we'll we got lastly but not leastly
simply faithfully home security with
home security there's two ways you can
go about protecting your home there's a
traditional way where you wait weeks for
a technician to do a messy installation
that costs a small fortune or there's
the other way simply safe simply safe is
everything you need in homes in a home
security system it's an award it's
award-winning protection two-time winner
of CNET Editors Choice Award you got to
get this [ __ ] okay especially now we
don't know where this pandemic is going
you want to know who's outside your
house alright you don't want to shoot
you're simply safe blankets your whole
home in safety you get comprehensive
protection for your entire home outdoor
cameras and doorbell alert and doorbells
alert you alert you to anyone
approaching your home entry motion and
glass breaks
sensors garden size you barely notice
it's there but what's truly remarkable
is you can set up this system all by
yourself
anyone can do it it takes 30 minutes to
an hour it's tops and there's absolutely
no trade-offs to your safety
you'll have an army of highly trained
security experts ready to dispatch
police to your home at a moment's notice
24/7 and it's only 50 cents a day with
no contracts it's why the verge calls
simply safe the best home security
system go to simply safe si MP Li si Fe
s AI
MP L is a Fe dot-com / / in the
summertime I'm gonna go to simply safe
calm / birth today and you'll go get
free shipping and a 60 day risk-free
trial you've got nothing to lose
go now and be sure you go to simply safe
calm / / that's simply safe calm / bird
you remember that for that old
commercial fr ie and dly tech Friendly's
home in the summertime used to go to
friendlies and buy their [ __ ] nuclear
green mint chocolate chip ice cream I
remember a time when [ __ ] mint
chocolate chip ice cream was the color
of the mint leaf instead of the
all-natural where it's hot why is it
that like 90% of men their favorite ice
cream is mint chocolate chip you know I
like mint chocolate chip and I like
[ __ ] Oreo cookie alright
always kid new vanilla Swiss almond you
know but my one of my favorite ones ever
those those [ __ ] - there was - [ __ ]
up in Maine where the [ __ ] Eddie and
Larry Ben and Jerry Ben and Jerry they
had a limited run I'm gonna look this up
I bet somebody's [ __ ] selling this for
a song
[Music]
a little way you want to hear the new
lyrics to that song
keep your distance booboo do get the
[ __ ] away from me I don't know you I
don't know if you got the disease doo
doo doo doo doo
why don't you stay the [ __ ] away from me
and my family
alright Ben & Jerry's ben and jerry's
pom pom pom pom Penn and cherries
[Music]
raspberry coconut it was the best
[ __ ] ice cream I ever had Ben &
Jerry's raspberry gon coconuts frozen
yogurt go [ __ ] his frozen yogurt should
be [ __ ] illegal Jesus Christ you ever
[ __ ] run into somebody you think you
know them and then they turn out to be
somebody else that's the [ __ ] ice
cream vote that's what [ __ ] yogurt
frozen yogurt is what a [ __ ] is it wait
a minute was it frozen yogurt back in
the day I'm dead it was like 20 years
ago
best and worst Ben and Jerry's flavors
ranked all right Ben & Jerry's recently
brought online ice cream shopping to
their website how do they keep it frozen
all right hang on a second it's Ben and
Jerry's cookies and cream cheese cake
core bold idea but way too sweet Ben and
Jerry's boom choc a lotta cookie core
again good idea but too much core Ben &
Jerry's vanilla solid but not exciting I
mean just look at the description of it
that's how spoiled we are in first world
countries it's only vanilla you know you
didn't melt a Hershey bar and stick some
cookie dough in there with some
cheesecake I mean what that's not ice
cream
all right let me get to the goddamn
reeds for this week all right crying
celebrities hey Bill you see that video
of the celebrity crying to his Instagram
because he felt bad for what the world
was going through no and I'm glad I
didn't I'm really glad I didn't oh my
god I gotta watch this
Jesus Christ is it gonna be celeb I
gotta see this Oh Mike what why would
you tell me this exists celebrity cries
video that'll be a zillion videos about
pandemic Josh GAD shares video of
himself crying to let people know I love
Josh GAD I don't want to watch this guy
crying then it's okay to cry oh boy
people don't send me this [ __ ] I love
you no Josh GAD did a [ __ ] TV show
with Billy Crystal it was it was such a
[ __ ] great goddamn show the [ __ ] was
it called hey I was second I got to look
it up you know this is actually a bad
thing to well maybe if you guys watch it
they'll [ __ ] reboot it Josh all right
hang on a second the [ __ ] I would Josh
GAD Billy Crystal okay okay the
comedians how hilarious is that I'm a
[ __ ] comedian I could remember was
called the comedians they were so
goddamn amazing the writing was so
[ __ ] great on that show I still can't
believe that there wasn't an uproar that
that got taken off they didn't bring it
back that was such a [ __ ] the episode
with the two of them meet each other
neither one of them wants to work with
each other but they
both in this point in their careers
where they need each other to do a
[ __ ] show they have this total
showbiz lunch and then this afterwards
is they're both driving away talking to
their [ __ ] agents saying what they
really felt was just [ __ ] them it was
a [ __ ] amazing show and anyway I half
the reason why I don't want to I don't
want to see this guy I don't wanna see
another man cry I just I can't I can't
handle it all right I don't have the
emotional maturity to handle it so god
bless him that he can do it all right
hey Bill you see that video of a
celebrity crying to his Instagram
because he felt bad for the world what
the world is going through why broadcast
that if you want to even have the
conversation about how famous people can
help how about we start with not crying
you put some quote put our weakest
feelings forward is that how you want to
play it I'm not even saying crying as a
week I'm just saying
broadcasting your pain thinking it's
going to make someone else not alone as
Little Jimmy Norton would say yuck that
just reminded how much I miss Jim Norton
I used to see him at least five days a
week back in the day you know even right
through Opie and Anthony I used to see
him all the time now I'm lucky if I see
that guy two three times a year
what a [ __ ] comedic mind on that guy
now you're gonna make me cry cuz I miss
Jimmy you know people can do what they
want to do I mean I think a lot of your
reaction has to do with your feelings
about crying but I definitely get it
alright this crying video for you is
watching me and my president is just
sitting there [ __ ] himself [ __ ]
playing the blame game like some [ __ ]
chick I didn't mean to china started it
it's like dude come on man balls
here I don't need your [ __ ] blaming
people
I mean he's acting like the owner of the
[ __ ] Baltimore Colts you lost the
playoff game boho get a better team come
back next year you [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
doing our own investigation lounge by
the way I have a conspiracy
I don't think China started this [ __ ]
thing all right
I don't think China started the [ __ ]
coronavirus you know I started thinking
started the coronavirus okay
I think the NFL started it the NFL
started it to destroy the XFL all right
now I know a lot of you guys are rolling
your eyes but all you have to do you
guys do a little gumshoe work here who
stood to profit the most the NFL look at
the NFL the NFL got to play their whole
[ __ ] season the NBA had to shut it
down NHL shut it down MLB shut it down
golf shutdown XFL shutdown when did when
did we finally take coronavirus
seriously about three weeks after the
Super Bowl
what do we do to come out of our houses
right before the NFL preseason I'm
telling you they started this [ __ ]
because they were scared of two forward
passes behind the line of scrimmage on
the same [ __ ] play they were like
what is this the [ __ ] AFL you're
gonna make it more exciting than our
product we don't have enough [ __ ]
room they're in too many of these cities
we're already in they're gonna eat into
our [ __ ] profits we're not going to
be able to go down to Florida
[Applause]
and they [ __ ] that's what they did
they put it out there they put it out
there and they went to [ __ ] China
just like the NBA and they started it
there because they knew that our
president was a racist and he would get
[ __ ] they needed that misdirection and
then you know before anybody figured it
out they sent Tom Brady to Tampa so that
became the story in the NFL it's just a
theory
all right right on cue hang in there
owners of the XFL I love a start-up
League here it is built the Justice
Department has quietly asked Congress
for the ability to ask Chief judges to
detain people indefinitely without a
trial during emergencies part of a push
for new power that comes as the corona
virus spreads through United States oh
god oh my god why are we doing this to
our country are we at the end of the
Ponzi scheme so they need to do this why
would you want to do that to people
oh my god am I really gonna open this
link I'm not gonna read this Department
of Justice seeks new emergency powers
amid corona virus pandemic and I know
what people are gonna say they get it's
gonna be like well that's just for
[ __ ] idiots who keep going outside
they're putting us all in jeopardy okay
and then how is that applied in the
future
all right that's terrifying I'm trying
to stay in a good mood there's nothing I
can do about that so I'm not reading it
and everybody else you got will put the
limpkin link up you can read it
coronavirus and DNA hey billy rusty nips
and like that one i noticed that only
celebrities athletes and politicians
seems to be able to get a four
coronavirus test the rest of us seem to
be relegated to a drive-through deep
swab of the nose it occurred to me that
the powers that be may be trying to gain
easy access to our DNA profiles oh yeah
do they there's always this [ __ ] going
on
in the past we as a country have been
taken advantage of when we're panicking
9/11 and the Patriot Act for instance
what's your take on it well yeah I mean
I've been preaching that [ __ ]
[ __ ] forever I hope I'm wrong
because there's no paperwork no
explanation of where or when someone can
access it having said that I hope you
and your family stay safe from the virus
and the bill bird podcasts had me dying
especially when you drank an orange
Fanta was your ginger Jesus Christ you
spelt it wrong I don't weave your ginger
Faton level dropping or something I
don't know what you're trying to say
there
thanks for the left now go [ __ ] yourself
yeah that's like my that's my energy
drink I love an orange Fanta with real
sugar in it go [ __ ] yourself like I like
that and I like root beer all right and
you that's all you need to know about me
you see me drinking orange Fanta that's
how I can be the strongest ginger I can
be you see me drinking a root beer and
that's you know let's you know I like
black chicks my wife would say oh Jesus
what do you do a Billy two bites if you
had information that someone in
Hollywood was a pedophile what would you
do yeah I go I call the authorities
I wouldn't [ __ ] go into their house
like that chicken [ __ ] Silence of the
Lambs trying to solve it myself the
goddamn [ __ ] virtual reality glasses
on if that's what you're thinking
assuming you go to the authorities okay
yeah yeah I would
but what if you don't have actual
evidence that you can turn in do you
start making jokes about them on stage
the podcasts or Twitter Corey Feldman
seems to be having trouble getting
people to care even though all of his
stories have surprisingly all been
corroborated yeah I don't know what I
think because he's a guy that nobody
gives a [ __ ]
you know I also don't think that it
helps his cause that he's dresses like
Michael Jackson you know on the bad
album all the time I don't think that
that helps either he hasn't had a hit
movie in a while these are the things
that don't make your story real to
people so which is wrong you know maybe
he's dressing like that do you dread do
you know do you end up dressing like the
person that abused you I don't [ __ ]
know did Michael would be I don't know I
don't I don't I don't I don't know I I
don't know I don't know what that means
Jesus Christ what a topic to [ __ ]
bring up okay if I had information that
someone in Hollywood was a petal what
would you do
find an amp evidence then how would I
know how would I know I would be like
that guy in rear window I would just be
[ __ ] sitting there Jimmy Stewart I
would just be sitting there watching his
[ __ ] house I don't know I don't know
what I would do I mean if there was kids
over there I would if well first of all
I keep my kid away from that person and
then I would try to somehow talk to one
of the kids slip it into conversation
hey what'd you get for Christmas is that
dude you're living with touching you in
a way that you don't like hey I was just
asking that's so [ __ ] that's a big
question to ask because if the kid says
no then you're like I'll [ __ ] is he
gonna say yeah it's [ __ ] horrible but
I can't tell you those pedophiles
anybody does anything to an animal a kid
or a woman or a world economy that takes
advantage of people should be executed
that's it
get rid of Flat Earth rebuttals dear
Billy beyond meat burger
it's bur ok read that better dear Billy
beyond meat burger tits birth I've been
losing my mind hearing about these flat
earthers so I want wanted to voice some
simple ways to show they are wrong I
will start with the North Star argument
during the time of the Egyptians what we
consider the North Star otherwise known
as Polaris is that a bus company wasn't
directly north
they named the star Thuban around 3,000
BC and it wasn't directly north the
earth rotates on an axis like a top and
there is a precession where what we
consider the North moves where what we
consider the North moves through
thousands of years of precession gubin
shifted in the sky and is now north
every year Earth's precession is slowly
shifting Polaris out of the northern
position and around 13,000 years from
now the star vigan will be the new North
Star Omega sorry vegan oh the old
Hollywood it's in my head
the second point I wanted to make deals
with flying at high altitudes at
altitudes above 30,000 feet the naked
eye can see the curvature I flight
Gulfstream five aircraft and we
routinely fly above 40,000 feet and the
curvature is easily seen third one
writer said that there's been no
experiment to prove the earth is round
but that is patently false over 2,000
years ago a Greek mathematician named
Arif the feni's did a simple experiment
the simplest way to explain is that he
measured the shadow that a stick casted
at the exact time 800 kilometres apart
and saw that there was a seven degree
difference between them proving that the
earth is a sphere and I thought
everything you said made sense except
for that I mean this
rolling hills this [ __ ] flatlands I
mean I don't I mean what about a
moldable if I look at a mogul and I
stick a stick on either side of that if
I just prove that the earth is wrong I
I'm too dumb for this conversation the
last point I wanted to make is how we
can how we can be certain we went to the
moon when we went to the moon we left
mirrors at documented locations that was
part of the experiment experiment to
confirm the speed of light in some other
gravity tests you can actually replicate
this experiment yourself with a
high-powered laser and computer
equipment which was actually done on the
show Big Bang Theory if we didn't go to
the moon how come we can target mirrors
at precise locations and get returns
that confirm the speed of light anyway
I'm too amused by flat-earthers
but remember right anyways I too am
amused by flat earthers but then I
remember that they are allowed to vote
and reproduce hopefully all is well with
you take care and go [ __ ] yourself yeah
you know you got pilots of some of the
[ __ ] greatest people on the planet
they really are they just I don't know
they got this great combination of
knowledge scientific knowledge and balls
anybody can learn that the [ __ ] earth
is flat on the ground but the [ __ ]
getting a goddamn jet and fly at 40,000
feet with pressurized [ __ ] air and
all of that [ __ ] I mean that's just it's
just [ __ ] amazing and I cannot tell
you how much I miss it
I really really really really really
really I missed the whole thing I miss
the way it smells
I'm Ishmael Ron Burgundy and when all of
this bullshit's over I'm gonna get back
up there I don't know I don't know I
don't know obviously with what happened
to Kobe and everything there was a bunch
of people telling me not to do it
anymore
which I understand but then there's also
the other thing is like you know I
wouldn't [ __ ] fly and [ __ ] like that
I fly in clear days with no turbulence
alright I'm a weekend warrior in 99% of
the times I fly I'm flying with an
instructor can I just have a good
[ __ ] time well you know i'mma tell
you this right now we're all gonna get
out of this and we're all gonna be you
know so you know what's great about this
this is gonna really make everybody
hopefully appreciate you know a lot of
things like the way my grandparents
lived through the depression like my
grandparents had to make their American
dream come true three times they made it
come true you know started a
dry-cleaning business and then the
Depression wiped them out and then they
got it going again and then World War
two came and my grandfather got drafted
or he enlisted I don't know Greatest
Generation he probably enlisted and that
wrecked him again and then when they
came out of it they built it back up
again and I got a lot on my gran because
it was these the how complex life is now
and I look back then you know I read I
read this book blueberries for Sal for
my daughter right she loves that and one
morning in Maine was Robert McCluskey
whatever the hell his name is
I gotta get his name right because he's
really my these are gonna be books like
someday if I live long enough because
I'm an old dad to become a grandfather
if I ever see my daughter reading one of
these books so it went to my grandson or
granddaughter I'm gonna put Josh GAD to
shame with the tears that flow out of my
[ __ ] freckled face here all right
blueberries for Sal
blueberries for Sal by Robert ya
McCluskey if you just look at the
simplicity in that in one morning in
Maine if you just look at their lives
you know because the the illustrations
are incredible the stoves and just
there's no TV screens and computers and
cell phones and all of that everything's
made out of glass metal and wood there's
no plastic it was a much simpler time
you know you could also [ __ ] die from
a lot of things you can't die from now
and polio and all that I do understand
that but there there's got to be a way
to marry those two worlds because in one
morning in Maine Sal's a little bit
older and now has a baby sister Jane and
she wakes up in a tooth is loose spoiler
alert right and bla bla bla bla bla she
comes downstairs for breakfast and then
she goes out and her dad's in Maine
digging for clams and just on the way
all the wildlife she sees and this it's
just a May it's just a [ __ ] you know
they go to town and this guy fixes their
outboard motor it's just like local
people in that type of [ __ ] not grantee
you know people a lot more racist back
then or overtly racist back then I don't
know sometimes some of the [ __ ] Trump
says and people don't have a problem
with it makes me think that that shit's
just still out there but I like to think
people are a little better now
I don't know so my grandparents kind of
lived a life like that and they had a
dry cleaner dry cleaning business and my
grandfather was the coolest dude ever he
always made sure my grandmother had a
new car every couple of years and then
he was frugal as hell he always drove a
used car and then he was a member of
daily living this little town and there
was a country club down there and he was
a member you know what I mean and they
just lived this really great life
he paid for his house cash back when you
could do that before you know all of
this [ __ ] you know you could make a
wage and then you know when I was a kid
like the milkman had could have a
stay-at-home mom it's [ __ ]
stay-at-home wife mother to his kids in
just I don't know it was it just a
different time I don't know I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm going with this [ __ ]
but uh I'm just thinking that maybe if
we go through this stuff he could maybe
live a more simple life
and personally I'm trying to as I always
try to I try to go to mom-and-pop places
as much as I can and I'm just hoping
during this time where the big dogs take
advantage of the little dogs that when
we come out of this [ __ ] we can [ __ ]
you know walk around and be amongst each
other again we can actually you're gonna
what's the word when you go to small
businesses
I don't begins with a P but if you go
and spend your money at those [ __ ]
places all right all the bigger places
they're gonna be fine all right
anyway so anyone talking about Brent
girlfriend doesn't like me watching
sports well she got her dream because
it's not on ESPN Oh Jo dear Billy
tremendous burr no I guess I say
tremendous a lot I know you haven't been
doing relationship advice for a while
but I hope you get to Rio I would love
to oh my god here we go look at this
look at this I get to play my little
[ __ ] jingle come on play play where
is it oh Jesus I can't queue up in come
on
[Applause]
hey that's me else alright let's see
this person wants advice from little old
me you know when you guys ask me for
advice I have to tell you it's really
just a humbling thing these guys this
[ __ ] silly there's a great one here
I'm getting a lot of credit by some of
and Ruth M Alyssa's it's all and Ruth
Ellis the music that comes out for the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast
Night Moves that song Mexico listen that
great [ __ ] band that's all familis he
knows all of that [ __ ] so my drum
teacher actually told me this band
jellyfish that put out a couple albums
one of which I've just been listening on
a [ __ ] loop
it's called spilt milk in the fact that
this [ __ ] thing came out in 1993 with
you know hair metal gone and then
everybody was into [ __ ] grunge and
the Seattle sound and all that and that
that these guys put out this [ __ ]
album that sounds like somewhere between
like Queen and this big [ __ ] like I
don't know what 70s rock that was put
out 1993 is incredible and not to
mention that the drummer is the lead
singer so when everybody anybody ever
says I'm sorry I'm typing this at the
same time what anybody ever says who's
who's one of the best singing drummers
of all time there's a Phil Collins
they'll say Don Henley Dave Grohl don't
forget
Marvin Andrews Strummer Sturmer sorry
Marvin Andrew Sturmer and there's an
incredible live video that I will post
of them playing in Germany and just how
this band sounds in their harmonies how
lists live that that's human beings
doing this
and the fact that they had the balls to
put out a [ __ ] album like this in
1993 is just incredible [ __ ]
incredible so check them out if you get
a chance jellyfish
spilt milk and I hope if a bunch of
people download it they actually get
some [ __ ] money from it not just the
record companies all right so it's time
for advice all right
also my throat's all dry here by the way
I'm so psyched I'm not smoking [ __ ]
cigars so [ __ ] psyched my teeth are
white again I don't have to [ __ ] just
it's just it's just great it's great I
missed the hell out of them and I'll
[ __ ] have a nice big fat [ __ ]
Cuban when this whole thing is over but
uh because that'll be a special occasion
anyways I know you have been doing
relationship advice for a while but I
hope you get to read this email I'm 21
now you got your whole life ahead of you
I'm sorry drink a little throat cook tea
here and been with my girlfriend for
about a year and a half she's really
smart and funny lady and I love her to
death
she's an introvert and had and has a
very small friend Circle
she always says I'm her best friend and
loves telling me about her day
Howard day went when she was out with
other friends and I love to hear it too
well don't you guys just have the
perfect little young love life I'm happy
for you well that's great anyways I'm a
big football parentheses soccer fan and
avid follower of the club football club
FC Barcelona does FC stand for Football
Club or [ __ ] [ __ ] Barcelona and
watch almost all of their games one day
I had an interview which I blew and I
forgot that there was a match going on
when I got home it was halftime and Leo
Messi scored a hat-trick in the first
half now my girlfriend came online and
said she wanted to tell me about her day
out with their friends
I told her that I had to watch this
match she had not seen the message at
that time and I went to watch the match
after I returned I saw that she was mad
at me for leaving to watch the match she
says I already missed the first half and
why would I watch the rest of it like
it's some movie she said she wanted the
whole day for me to tell her story but
couldn't because of my interview and
then oh she said she waited the whole
day for me to tell her to tell her story
but she couldn't because of my interview
and then posted the most annoying
question do you love football
parenthesis soccer more than me
I didn't know what to say and in the end
I apologized just so she would stop
fighting he just became more of a man
sir I hate to say it but that's part of
being in a relationship with a woman all
right you're definitely gonna learn
about yourself they're definitely
amazing people but you are definitely on
a regular basis you're going to be
saying sorry not because you're sorry
just to calm their [ __ ] emotions
anyway he says but I feel like she could
have been more understanding I always
find time for her and I'm always there
for her when she's having a tough time
it was a story and it could have waited
45 minutes I love you you and the lovely
Nia's insight on this huge fan hope
you'll do a show in India soon hope all
three of you are doing well hang on a
second when the person you're with you
know that they [ __ ] hear you and
they're just ignoring you
she just goes what are you ignoring me
oh I just wanted to tell you I loved you
she didn't buy that well great now I'm
gonna fight um all right this isn't such
a big deal I guess you just gotta kind
of I guess you you just have to
understand with women that for a lot of
them watching us watch sports is like us
watching them watch The Real Housewives
okay why do they watch it this is
[ __ ] stupid you know and you know God
knows my wife definitely as you can see
ignores the hell out of me but I'm a
douchey so I understand this is just so
I mean I don't think it's that big a
deal okay she had a you know she had a
typical female [ __ ] moment that's
that's where they go you know they need
to know every day that you love them
[ __ ] more than anything else and you
know every once in a while that rears
it's insecure head and all right so
she's a little insecure
you just just be understanding this
isn't gonna happen every time you watch
a [ __ ] soccer match if it does I
would just say listen this is something
that I love I love to do it makes me
happy it keeps me in a good mood which
will keep me in a great mood and it
actually it actually helps our
relationship I know this is dumb I know
this has no effect on my life it's like
a soap opera it's a story I watch it
this ebbs and flows Daz ups and downs is
an emotional roller coaster going on
that I connect with and I really enjoy
it it makes me want to work out and stay
in shape and look good for you and I get
inspired by watching this I can tape the
games and you know I'll always be first
but I need to I just this is something
that I need to do and I know that you
have things
this in your life that are important to
you and if I'm ever trying to impede on
them I want you to tell me that because
I don't want to take that from you
because I love you just say all that
[ __ ] and then you can watch the
[ __ ] game all right you [ __ ]
corona free [ __ ] I hope your
Corona free I hope I am too we're all
gonna find out and I promise you if I
get Corona do I have to [ __ ] if I
podcast by myself through Corona well I
will I be like [ __ ] that that'll be
like my Michael Jordan flu game right no
it won't bill alright I hope I don't get
it
God knows I have done enough [ __ ]
shows while this thing was out there
impact theaters I shook plenty of
[ __ ] hands
but I'm thinking those shows are far
enough away but you know I'm still post
mating and [ __ ] like that I'm doing the
best I [ __ ] can you know what I mean
so but I am definitely you know I
haven't had any friends over or anything
like that so it's just been me my my
lovely wife my beautiful daughter and
you know we usually have somebody come
by the house these cleaning people once
every couple of weeks and we just said
listen we'll keep paying you just don't
come by blah-blah-blah-blah-blah so they
were like cool we appreciate it
and old freckles for the first time in
[ __ ] years broke out the vacuum
cleaner and now I'm man enough to admit
I [ __ ] like it I like vacuuming I
like cleaning up and I actually think I
do a [ __ ] great job you know cuz I
live here you know what I mean so what I
do is I just sort of vacuum you know the
upstairs one day and in a couple days
later I do the downstairs and then
that's it and then you know I gotta get
a little dust rag to and I just figure
I'm gonna do one room one room every day
cuz then dusting isn't bad it's just one
room boom boom boom boom boom right just
my little [ __ ] thing there right like
learning a couple of French words I'll
just dust something once a day so
everybody can do everything right you
can [ __ ] handle your [ __ ] there all
right shout out to everybody who is
smart enough to have a veggie garden in
their backyard all of that stuff people
who got chickens and stuff like that so
you got eggs and everything you really
did a smart it's really paying off
Doomsday Preppers you were right you
were [ __ ] right flat earthers you know
the jury's still out is the information
comes in now I'm thinking it's round
again is there mirrors up there can I go
to Radio Shack and get a laser and then
I shoot it and it [ __ ] reflects back
at me what are you worried what a flat
earth is gonna say that it actually went
up there and it hit God's sunglasses and
came back does Jesus wear sunglasses he
does have long hair like Jim Morrison um
is everybody in alright
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on you
on Thursday
look at that I was a doomsday prepper my
never haven't guessed so Brearley having
guests on my podcast i just did an hour
in 22 minutes all by my lonesome huh I'm
gonna Pat myself on the back and then
[ __ ] sanitize both my hands and my
[ __ ] my back you know just so I don't
cross infect myself and then you get Co
vid 20 alright [ __ ] you I'll talk to you
later
god Bless America and China and
everywhere else ain't Cuba take it in
everybody god bless him alright bye